- I'm here to perform the
art of freestyle rap for you.
(audience laughs)
Of course invented in England.
It's rap that is made on
the spot, it's improvised.
It's never been rehearsed
and it's based on your suggestions.
So everyone, think of a word,
think of topic, or phrase
you'd like to hear rap about.
There's some rules,
don't say, "One second."
- Kanye West.
(audience laughs)
Don't say, "Food, or animals."
Animals are too, obvious, okay?
Be creative, best suggestion ever
was a German man who said,
"A day in the life of
an Aztec high priest."
Try and be (mumbles)
So you said, "Kanye west."
What is it about Kanye
West, that entices you,
so a man undergoing
mental health struggles
and a messy divorce.
(audience laughs)
- Everything.
- Everything?
Could be more specific
like, Kanye West surfing,
or Kanye West eating a
lollipop or whatever.
(audience chuckles)
No you can make it up, it
doesn't have to be real.
Kanye West has never eaten a lollipop.
(chattering indistinctly)
Yeah.
Oh, you didn't listen to what
the instructions were before,
and just shouting "Kanye west!"
Did you get confused?
Now is like, I'm gonna rap,
and you were like, "This is Kanye West."
(audience laughs)
It's hard to decipher
behind this big shades
with the lines in.
Well, what we can do, we can
come to this side of the room,
so let's get suggestion
from this side of the room.
What you guys wanna a rap about?
- Obama pleasuring himself.
- Yeah, cool why not!
(audience claps)
- Chicago!
- Well the thing is, that
is a great suggestion.
And then Chicago is just a locale.
- Yeah, it's Kanye and Obama.
- Wait, what do you say?
- Could do Kanye and Obama.
- You could do that.
Well, because they're both black,
is that why you said that?
(audience laughs)
- From Chicago!
- Oh they're both from Chicago,
I don't fucking know, are they?
Good fact.
- There you go.
Cool, thank you
yeah, that's a good thing.
Let's get another
suggestion from this side.
- Colonization.
- Okay calm down, mate, right?
(audience laughs)
What's the issue with that?
We just want to turn up
and make places better.
(audience laughs)
And steal all your things.
But also...
(audience continues laughing)
Are you from a place that we colonized?
(audience laughs)
(man chattering indistinctly)
No, okay.
You can do better and do better than that.
- I got one for you.
- Yeah do it.
- [Man 2] You're an alien
and you're watching all this bullshit.
- (chuckles) An alien
watching all this bullshit.
- All this shit.
- Yeah man, that's cool.
Okay, "Obama pleasuring himself"
"An alien watching all this crazy shit."
I bet he spent a lot of time on Reddit,
that's what they tend to do.
(audience laughs)
That's not a dis, that's
a good place to be.
People around here, what
would you like rap about?
(woman talking indistinctly)
- Yeezy eating ass.
- Oh, Yeezy eating ass, okay.
(people chattering indistinctly)
Would you know, look, look,
you don't have to base
it on what they say,
Although, the "Yeezus" is
my favorite Kanye album.
That is the one where he first introduces
the concept of eating ass.
Now, that sounds almost like,
"Kanye, are you crazy?"
Which is not the word you should use,
because he genuinely does
suffer from mental issues.
And now everyone's eating ass,
he's a trendsetter, right?
(audience laughs)
Everyone uses oil, chin
and sparse arrangements,
this man's a genius!
I'm beginning to giving respect, so okay.
So what we'll just say we've
got "Kanye eating ass,"
"Aliens watching all this shit,"
"Obama pleasuring himself."
Let's get another one.
- British women.
- British women?
- Yeah!
- Are you British?
- Nah!
- Nah, you ever fucked a British girl?
- Nah way!
- Nah wah?
(audience laughs)
What wrong them girls, man?
- The teeth are fucked up!
- The teeth are fucked up.
Yeah, they snug on your cock, whatever.
(audience laughs)
- They're orange!
- They're orange?
Well they are if they're
in Essex or New Castle,
that is true, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- I'm Irish.
- Okay, yeah, that's two
strikes against British women.
(audience continues laughing)
Okay, so to remind you, then we've got
"Kanye eating ass."
(audience laughs)
God, this is why I don't do late shows,
'cause you're all vulgar.
(audience laughs)
"Obama pleasuring himself."
We've got, "British women,"
and how you don't wanna fuck 'em.
"Aliens watching all this shit"
and "Colonization," I guess
we'll throw it in there, right?
Let me, this is all
tangled up for some reason,
I bet this was Kevin's doing.
(audience laughs)
Trying to sabotage me.
Right, okay, cool, this is a freestyle,
that's the beat I'm gonna start with,
based on all that shit.
It's gonna be fun
and not as shitty as
you'd expect me to be.
(audience whooping)
(audience claps)
You don't need to clap, I
brought my own music (mumbles)
♪ Oh man in the White House ♪
♪ Setting alarm some people in the south ♪
♪ 'Cause my man Obama be
rocking up the first president ♪
♪ With the dark skin than anyone before ♪
♪ And today is your dream ♪
♪ He'd be there, yeah
does it real properly ♪
♪ Get a hand shandy in the Oval Office ♪
♪ He dunking there on the desk ♪
♪ We know that Obama doin' his best ♪
♪ Because he's a self-starter ♪
♪ Dick bigger the Jimmy Carter ♪
♪ Well JFK, I'm a charmer ♪
♪ Wanking, when he gets an issue ♪
♪ Doesn't use a presidential
sock or tissue ♪
♪ I don't know, it goes so well ♪
♪ But talks well, when
he nuts and he's like ♪
♪ Michelle, come on here ♪
♪ So much more than she's swimming ♪
♪ The only thing he won't fuck ♪
♪ White women from my
country and in the U.K ♪
♪ Welcome bad teeth, it's what you say ♪
♪ You're like Nah Chris ♪
♪ They're ever so deranged ♪
♪ They got back molars
and they're so orange ♪
♪ I wanna make sure they're
not the color of flame ♪
♪ May be in the future,
we'll colonize again ♪
♪ We've gonna run around ♪
♪ Yeah, we're in for sure ♪
♪ We're gonna go take China and India ♪
♪ Once more, then I tell
you what the queen do ♪
♪ Coming over here and she invade you ♪
♪ And maybe she probably dead by then ♪
♪ But Prince Charles will come in ♪
♪ Invading like Sir Joe Biden ♪
♪ And Prince coming in with a glock ♪
♪ Now what do you think ♪
♪ And Joe's down there
on the floor saying ♪
♪ Oh, I'm sorry, Charles. ♪
♪ Yes, you know, that I adore
the empire that you had ♪
♪ Fancy that, think that
we tried to join you ♪
♪ With Iraq and Afghanistan ♪
♪ We went, we were like a team ♪
♪ Kanye West, oh man, is such
a green with production ♪
♪ And all the raps I'm
about did late Graduation ♪
♪ College Drop Out ♪
♪ But then he did stuff more recently ♪
♪ Like Ye, I was like, not
pleased to see that bullshit ♪
♪ But it don't mind, top class
when I listened to Yeezus ♪
♪ Oh my, it blew my mind ♪
♪ And I was like, this is a blast ♪
♪ I want to crank up the shit ♪
♪ While he's eating ass ♪
♪ He was damn right I can ♪
♪ So people say it's wrong ♪
♪ But he's broken rectum with his tongue ♪
♪ Know when he's down there
with her ass cheek splayed ♪
♪ Probably he was wearing those shades ♪
♪ I was like, oh lick it
while the shit's brown ♪
♪ I'm call that, a I real love lock down ♪
♪ Then we go shit on his mouth ♪
♪ He can't talk ♪
♪ But still he made through
the Wire and Jesus Walks ♪
Thanks everybody!
(audience applauds)